we don't know
all right
um
let's play a dutch
rare
for sure for me
all right that's pretty tame start so
what's crossing my mind already is that
i don't have to worry about the dark
square bishop coming out and about here
can be a disruptive piece and also e4 in
one swing
you know these are these variations
where the centers opened up very fast
uh that's doesn't seem
like it will be
the most precise way forward from for
white from here
could have probably thrown that move on
before i shared those thoughts but
all right
this is where we are also
first things to think to note that is
under attack
and i could defend it in multiple ways
boom boom boom i'm leaning more towards
e6 excuse me d6
because i want to create a duo with this
pawn
i want to get this guy here
so duos are a strength
i may even
be looking forward to uh
you know
an e4 fork
i think i want to begin with this
yeah
it's a very flexible move
what i don't want to do is put the pawn
here and create a big gap on e5
this knight's eyes will light up
this move can be prevented
on white's next turn
this is the main one
this one is well but that's not without
its issues so
i'm able to get an e5
and i probably should do that straight
away
um
yeah
they're allowing me to create this duo
let's do it
and now i am a step away
this is this is one of the things that i
think about once i have established two
pawns on my own fourth rank pandua on my
fourth rank that next level that next
thing you can look forward to one day is
establishing a space invader pawn
so i think their
reaction is all right
um
let's see how they follow up however
that is not the way to follow up i don't
think
i was thinking the ways to play e4
strike at this duo
immediately
now i think the assessment is that black
is clearly better
this night
its favorite square has been taken away
because of this last move
the this move i imagine is designed at
stopping e4
but i'm
i'm
satisfied if this duo simply
sits it's fine where where they're at so
what am i looking at right now
i don't have a pawn on d6 anymore and i
don't think it's worthwhile to go
forward with the fianchetto which is
something that may have come about if
e3 wasn't played on move two
um definitely leaning towards bishop on
c5 i think it is the best square
so let's do it
a bishop on c5 it is unprotected but no
tricks to take advantage of it
i do have to be careful once i castle i
guess
uh that's what i'm signing up for when
you play the dutch
and you castle you have to always be
careful of this open diagonal these two
guys
in particular can definitely cause some
problems so
i'm really only looking as far as bishop
on c5 queen e7 in castles
i'm not quite sure where i want to go
with this knight i imagine this bishop
will eventually go here
some kind of bishop
takes and then here with double attack
against my king an unprotected bishop
can
be nearby so what they're looking at
right now i imagine is the more direct
stuff defend this pawn
i'm gonna make this
um
i'm gonna make this move right
here and not give away any information
yet with this knight i'm not quite sure
where it wants to go if i play here
straight away maybe i have to
be a little concerned about some pin
bishop b5 right now i could block with
the pawn or the bishop
if this pawn moves i'll lean more
towards knight c6 because it has that d4
square this move is almost always going
to be met with f4 and then i have a huge
outpost here
on e3
so this knight where it's forward moves
i'm not really really concerned about
that
can't go to f4 if it goes here it's not
connected with anything on the white
side
castles check
here knight g5
can actually be a bit disruptive since
white hasn't castled kingside
because h6 trying to scare the knight
away can maybe be met with h4
though maybe i could go ahead and
capture it's a little scary the queen
isn't easily able to make use of the h5
square with a pawn on f3
but still i'm thinking a little bit less
about kingside castles right now
i wonder if there's a way i could
control the c4 square
this really knocks out two key pieces
i also have to go faster
i could begin with bishop here i could
also maybe think about h6 first
it's really is h6 really so
bad
maybe knight c6 first
yeah tell you what let's go with knight
c6
yeah bishop b5 i could go here i could
go queenside
why why am i why am i not thinking a bit
more about queenside castles
yeah maybe i don't even go kingside
i this is a completely open file so i
should have been thinking much sooner
about castling queenside
now this this is an open file
completely open file
and so i get that nice benefit of king
safety and rook active rook activity in
one swing so this is i guess prep work
for
b4 or at the very least it's a
controller
controlling my knight in bishop i don't
want to see these pieces start to get
kicked around
if i play this
maybe i don't want to castle queen side
as the thing but i guess we can't have
it all maybe i go kingside
castles bishop check king in the
corner is that really something to be
worrying about let's let's go with this
first
i'm leaning more towards kingside
castles now
[Laughter]
because this this side of the board can
easily be opened up
we'll see what kind of decision this guy
makes
if this rook it is no longer on this
file okay
i definitely want to stay on this
diagonal the knight is under control and
vulnerable
a4 with tempo
knights on these squares do not like
being attacked by rook pawns this is
usually
desirable moves
boom
boom
these kind of moves for both sides
all right down three minutes
usual case
two pot two healthy pawns on the fourth
opponent's pawns are set back
as a result their minor pieces feel a
bit clumsy and these guys stand well all
on the third rank so still for the
moment
my opponent is keeping me guessing as to
which side of the board he'll go to
now after the knight is given a boot
boot
has to go to this square it's the only
safe square
do it
and i think i'm just gonna
castle actually those earlier points i
was making about
bishop check i could i can simply meet
it with the bishop block
that was also a possibility
getting uh
[Music]
too sophisticated with this
knight in bishop converging on these
squares i could immediately neutralize
it
though
no maybe the bishop check bishop there
the knight could still play here it is
supported
all right
i have a lead in development this knight
is clumsy both knights are not so not so
great i could look at blasting open type
of moves e4
maybe f4 after there's a pin on the e
pawn
see what happens with the e3 pawn okay
the knight it's going back
what do we do how to improve
be a developer
so now the time to play e4
bishop e6 continue to develop all four
minors on my third rank knights are
pretty
castles on board rook where do you go
open file
keep this pawn there
supported this could be a little
annoying
this is an interesting post for the
night
how would i react to this maybe that
yeah they're
i'm gonna go here it's not a high
quality move but i it's something fast
some security here maybe they're going
for
some aggressive move
i don't know but i am back on the clock
i'm not quite sure how to break down
this position it's it's still compact i
have space but it's
i don't know
maybe straight away going for a doubling
on the d file was best
instead of g6 maybe we could have done
without that
if g4 how am i reacting i might just
throw the king in the corner
chop chop and then i'm ready to fight on
the g file should it open
my knight's given a push
okay
um let's go here
oh they're opening up that square for
the knight but maybe they end up in a
pickle
pin
there's no knight move with a check that
would attack my unprotected bishop on c4
and because this rook stays here
you can't go here and be in a spot to
recapture with the a pawn so if you play
the b pawn i could exchange and
the ac pawns are isolated
i could look at this idea
seeing that one now
just feels
much cozier so i'm gonna go for this
so i've gained a little something
structurally they have they're going to
have split pawns
not sure what should take so now that
these guys are split and isolated i
could look at the squares immediately in
front of those isolated pawns as homes
for my pieces so this one has my
attention
c4
and
i think i want to go in for it right now
this also crossed my mind
here into here but i'm exchanging up
this
knight
for
i don't know if i want to really do that
trying to sneak in like this
here here i could maybe go for this kind
of stuff taking advantage of a pin
evening out evening out now on the clock
tournament's over
this guy ran away with that
jb2 mix
47
finishing on fire
what to note what should white do occupy
the d file
flight square for the king is a little
scary
ready to slither in here
this
maybe i go ahead and win a pawn
yeah i really i don't know if i really
want to do that
try and pile up on this guy
exchange knights
put all my attention here
win a pawn
this pawn controls their knight
i still like this duo
fourth ranked duo beats out the third
ranked duo
that move
i
wanted to play this and reply to it so
now i could actually think about
plata type
stuff
structurally even though it's
way open
on the queen side
lots of play here on the dna
there's probably more direct stuff
happening here so
that night what is it threatening
not really a whole lot i could go ahead
and throw them in a pickle
pineroni
and now this
has my full attention
this kind of stuff
and they may not get out of it
actually i like this this square better
out of the night moves with tempo
i don't think it matters a whole lot
also now that this move is in my bishop
c is all the way down to that first rank
so in the event of some g file opening
up which i don't think is a good idea
i'll have a much easier time of
controlling the
open g file
because i control that key pivot square
i don't think it's going to go in that
direction also these these kind of moves
are still there upon on g3
without this pawn and h2 these mating
ideas are really really close maybe oh
this is an additional reason i'm now
seeing rook here
these kind of mating
moves a sacrifice here rook h6 for mate
i'm controlling these two
so just like there's back rank mates
there can be a side file mate because of
this control so they are playing here
g4 giving me an opportunity to capture
and open up the king's side
um
i could simply ignore it
and double up
yeah
i'm uh i'm gonna ignore it
capture
that's unnecessary
i'm uh i'm keying in on the the pinned
knight
it takes night and it takes night
or that
both they're probably tipping in my
favor
these tricks here i don't believe are
working
chop chop here i could go here go here
there's pins this knight's out of play
my king's cozy
they're at 30.
final seconds i guess
when on time
there's maybe two tame of the setup
there for white right
move to e3 not the most testing
let's insist on this
i guess they're ready to uh
they ready to address this pin with
bishop b3
just trying to be precise right to the
very end oh actually
there's this
forget about it
let's go here
time winner
okay not the greatest finish there for
that game
all right
you